I don't know America doesn't really feel
like a big thing anymore like when I was
like America was like the biggest thing
there was dude it was like the biggest
company in the world was America right
it was like we're the biggest company
we're the number one on the Dow Jones
baby yeah USA that was it but now it
feels almost and maybe it's just because
I live in California it it almost feels
like in and I this isn't a political
statement but it doesn't feel weird to
rep America a little bit like if you
just see somebody wearing like a USA
t-shirt you almost look at them and you
and you you automatically associate who
they are politically and like who they
are and like how they eat [__] and like
how they shoot guns yeah they eat it
from the back yeah they're pulling hair
like it's a goddamn trucker but it feels
like
but like there's nothing wrong with you
it's like no there's nothing wrong in it
at all right because you'd see a guy
then uh with a Brazilian flag you're
like yeah that guy loves this country
exactly but you got with American
fighting like oh this guy might be some
right-wing Politico guy yeah but that
dude could be sucking [__] like his
[__] you know on some Joey Chestnut
[__] you know so you don't really know
what or where or how or why but like
something about the USA flag you think
you know that person specifically well
that's when it starts to feel like that
something like there must be the dark
artists that kind of run things whoever
they are or if there is
they you know
they've definitely started to dissolve
the idea of what it means to be American
to a lot of people you know but at the
same time it's like you have people
expressing all their rights and opinions
when they're lucky enough to live in a
country where you can express your right
opinions it's a great place but it's
only because they those things have been
like fought for and
um the government has been kept enough
in check yeah and the you know thing
it's only because like because easily
you could be Cuba or you could be
um what's another place
Europe Europe
Paris where they don't or you know what
I'm saying you could be another place
where you don't have the freedom yeah
yeah Russia dude my family's very
Russian and it's like I was I told
somebody the other day I was like I kind
of want to go back to like right now I
was like yeah what's up they're like
what do you mean what's up have you
heard of anything about Russian Ukraine
right now you're dumbass I'm like dude I
get all my news from laffy taffies and
Snapchat I'm not doing well in the head
brother I don't know what to tell you
but like in my eight but like I think we
take it for granted [__] USA you know
but if you see a guy with a Ford F350
and it's a wrapped USA you're like oh
this guy really means it this guy is on
a first name basis with a lot of Hooters
in town yeah yeah well I definitely
think there's like some traditionalism
but there are people who like use the
flag now also as like I'm gonna use the
flag as my way of showing how
um
conservative I am or I don't know but
there's also like libert like people
that have Liberty or like what is the
new thing it's
libertarian libertarian Olympic do they
use the American flag a lot
I feel like they do I feel like they
think that's hilarious dude yeah that's
like [__] some people would have an
ozempic flag outside dude and people
would be knocking at the door like you
got it I heard a girl at a bar maybe a
month ago she goes I think I'm going to
Mexico next week because ozempic is 800
cheaper I was like that sends a loan and
I was just looking at I was like why do
you have to be so goddamn hot that's
like like if I said that people like
you're an idiot but I heard that and I
was like I could see through the red
flags on this but like going across the
border to get diabetic medicine so you
can look thinner it's a wild time yeah
so the same way that we might say like a
USA flag might look weird on somebody
because it's two-page audit dude they're
looking at La be like you you [__]
are addicted to diabetic medicine right
[__] yeah put it in your zins dude
let's fire up
yeah I don't know and most of our are
like the military that protects our
country or keeps things like
you know will protect us if need be they
are
they have the American flag on their
[__] uniform so it's really weird to
get people who are like against America
like why have we created a people that
are against our own flag that's the
[__] weird thing to me it is bizarre
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one